[Musique]
si vous payez
on a deux médecins qui sont là les faire
entrer voilà le docteur plagié et le
docteur non mais j'ai mis moins n'est
pas simple et cd m qui parle a dit que
j'avais à dire et monsieur by van on va
faire la publicité de pro d2 il faut que
lui sinon c'est monsieur blaché
diskeeper rapporte beaucoup de gens à
dos donc et ils sont extrêmement
intégral ici on va les écouter et je
peux vous dire que je suis vraiment le
connaître et reggie vie quand il a
quelque chose à dire il le dit et il n'
y roule ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre et
le docteur bâches et non plus émis le
souvent des personnes ado je vous le dis
aussi donc la lave ou 10 de métier jimmy
quand vous entendez saxe munich battu
d'abord j'aimerais vous dire que moi
j'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts avec
n'importe quel laboratoire ni pour le
gouvernement ça permet de dire que
lorsque je vous parle je parle en toute
indépendance
alors j'ai un peu consterné quand je
vous entends puisqu'on vit une période
or voilà c'est dit je suis pas venu pour
parler de ça je ne suis pas médecin je
connais des médecins et je sais
aujourd'hui que on a empêché les
français d'avoir accès à des traitements
précoces je sais aujourd'hui que le
premier ministre dit qu'il n'y a pas de
traitement précoce ce qui est faux je
sais qu'aujourd'hui le premier ministre
dit que à part les vaccins n'y a aucune
autre solution je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui veulent absolument croire à
ça moi je dis qu'il ne faut pas croire à
ça j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
maintenant vous ferez
en termes de traitement possible mais la
première chose qu'on pouvait faire c'est
de mettre votre masque dans les couloirs
au lieu de vous balader sans masque bien
sûr ça n'engage que lui
voilà ce qui survient alors francis on
peut pas incriminer le président accusé
le président darmon francis alors
qu'avec ça n'engage que vous mais là si
ça n'engage que moi mes amis je veux
être clair avec tout le monde et nous je
n'étais pas d'accord pour parler de ça
comme ça c'est fait là je devais avoir
simplement un entretien avec cyril et
j'ai l'impression un peu de tomber dans
un piège dans ce match et on peut partir
s'il vous plaît je veux dire et je vais
je vais en terminer là parce que ce
monsieur m'a admonesté quand j'ai pas
non j'ai paris donc dormi c'est dans le
bourg des gens c'est pas bien non plus
comme chez ati courageux il fait puis
revient enfin que la silicose simplement
ce que je vais vous dire c'est que j'ai
peut-être tort où j'ai peut-être raison
il ya des gens qui pensent qu'en faisant
voter ça n'engage que moi voulait
surtout pas d'émission le voilà leur gho
à l'émission donc et je les dis quand
j'ai fait ma tribune sur france soir et
je veux rendre hommage à françois parce
que c'est pas france soir qui a publié
la fecq news
comme quoi j'aurais moi demandez un coup
d'état militaire ce sont des journaux
qui accuse françois de 10 de répondre
des faits que nous donc j'étais venu
pour parler cyril j'ai été amenée malgré
avec vous attends attends attends je
termine donc simplement je veux dire
ceci la meilleure façon de savoir si
j'ai raison la meilleure de façon de
savoir si oui ou non on a menti aux
français
la meilleure façon de savoir si on
aurait pu soigner les français et éviter
tout ce qui s'est passé en autorisant
les traitements précoces c'est qu'il ya
justement une procédure qui soit menée
une procédure soit menée par l'épaule
parlementaire et qui leur permettront de
faire la lumière sur toute cette affaire
si j'ai tort je serai le premier à
présenter des excuses et à dire je me
suis trompé j'ai eu tort mais si je n'ai
pas de corps ça veut dire qu'on a menti
aux français et qu'à cause de ses
mensonges répétés des françaises et les
français sont morts
et ça c'est absolument inacceptable
surtout quand les ordres sont donnés
dans oh voilà après moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose je suis pas comme eux
ces gens qui pensent que le président de
la république c'est dieu pour moi c'est
l'employé du peuple c'est pas le patron
du peuple là il veut se comporter comme
le patron du peuple et bien moi je veux
lui rappelait simplement qu'il est notre
employé et c'est ce que j'ai fait dans
ma tribune je suis fier de l'avoir fait
cette tribune je la soumet aux français
et c'est eux qui décideront si ma
tribune est fondée ou pas j'aime aller
embrasser pas franchir a dit de vous
dire je n'ai pas envie de me disent tu
dois d'abord je comprends l'exaspération
je comprends que beaucoup de français
est d'ailleurs pas les français on avait
encore les émeutes
aux pays bas il ya des gens qui sans
beurre doubt qui n'en peuvent plus parce
qu'il n'y a aucune perspective
mais malgré tout vous pouvez pas dire
que par exemple il se comporte comme un
dieu et il n'y a pas à payer des
commissions d'enquêté en permanence non
s'il vous plaît mais moi j'en ai assez
de deux jours et vous affrontez j'ai pas
envie de mettre en avant la vie de jim
et moi m'a dit vous en pensez de ça
alors avec tout le respect que je vous
dois je vous dois je trouve que votre
parler un peu confuse passer du coq à
l'âne ya un peu de par la lame du coq à
l'âne
il ya un peu de paranoïa dans ce que
vous dites est en fait le monde entier
ne me traitez de paranoïaque parce que
je m'en vais tout de suite ne vous ne
vous attaquez pas à moi répondez moi sur
mes arguments sont leurs côtés donc vous
êtes médecin je ne suis à m non mais le
gars il me dit que je suis paranoïaque
des ses bourreaux qui m'amuse à mon sens
y allemand c'est un peu la paranoïa
le monde entier a du mal à voir mais
j'en ai marre on s'est compliqué répond
qu'il dise pas que c'est de la paranoïa
y répondre en clamant écoute le mans
c'est là qu'est le langage de
l'inquisition
jimmy jeune amant qui est tout sauf ça
franchement un serial heures de mec tu
fais je le dis et je te jure vraiment eu
la doré jiminy franchement du mit je ne
suis pas paranoïaque je ne suis pas
médecin je l'adoré je suis un simple
citoyen et je vous affirme même sans
être médecin que les traitements
précoces existe
merci son fils à dire merci francky
clair si merci francis l'inversé on sy
savane est avec nous alors il doit
passer la main
voilà je vous embrasse merci en tout cas
c'est bon ce que j'aimais